l'intérieur pauleta madame stéphanie
pernaut baudot merci monsieur le
président j'associe à ma question mes
collègues députés du département de
l'ain charles de la verpillière xavier
breton michel voisin et damien abad
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
l'emploi et de la formation
professionnelle il est temps en cette
dernière séance de questions au
gouvernement de procéder un bilan de
votre quinquennat notamment en matière
d'emploi des jeunes et vous comprendrez
que notre bilan ne sera pas forcément de
la même teneur que le vôtre sur deux
sujets principaux
le premier c'est sur l'apprentissage
depuis 2012 les chiffres de
l'apprentissage ne cesse de baisser avec
un léger sursaut de -2 1% en 2015
et c'est une tragédie pour notre pays
pour plusieurs raisons parce que
l'apprentissage est une filière
d'excellence et aujourd'hui elle permet
à des jeunes françaises et des jeunes
français d'acquérir un métier un savoir
faire au sein des entreprises et demain
de devenir les entrepreneurs qui feront
vivre notre pays
l'apprentissage est perdu aujourd'hui
pour des choix que vous avez fait
notamment en matière économique et pour
la diversité des lois qui régissent
notamment la taxe d'apprentissage à
laquelle plus personne ne comprend rien
et qui met en difficulté de centre de
formation pour apprentis ou des
entreprises qui ne savent plus à qui
élevèrent cela taxes et des centres
aujourd'hui sont en difficulté parce
qu'elle ne la touche plus dû à la
complexité administrative que vous avez
mis en place l'autre bilan que nous
trouvons absolument désastreux de votre
gouvernement c'est la formation
professionnelle et là vous nous avez
fait quand même quelque chose
d'exceptionnel qui est le plan formation
pour lequel un matin le président de la
république qui n'a même pas eu le
courage de se présenter devant les
français pour présenter son bilan s'est
dit qu'il créerait 500000 formation afin
de permettre l'inversion de la courbe du
chômage c'est tout à fait vrai vous avez
le droit de ne pas d'accord mesdames
messieurs mais c'est la vérité et
pourquoi c'est la vérité parce qu'un
milliard 3 a été pris sur la dette pour
mettre en formation des jeunes et aussi
des chômeurs et leur demander si à un
moment donné ils pourraient pas aidé le
président à atteindre ses objectifs par
ma question est simple madame la
ministre
ne me parlez pas de 2012 je n'étais pas
là vous non plus quel bilan pouvez vous
faire de votre politique désastreuse de
la formation dans ce pays
la parole est à madame myriam el khomri
ministre du travail de l'emploi de la
formation professionnelle et du dialogue
social
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
madame la députée stéphanie pernaut
baudon je vous remercie de votre
question et je vais permettre ici d'y
répondre
il ya quelques mois vous dénonciez dans
ce même hémicycle l'absence de résultats
du gouvernement en matière d'emploi
depuis les faits vous ont donné tort en
le nombre de demandeurs d'emplois a
diminué et cent mille demandeurs
d'emploi en 2016 et ceci a été
principalement au bénéfice des jeunes
notamment en 2016
le nom de jeunes demandeurs d'emploi
sans activité a reculé de près de 8 8% 6
4% s'agissant du département de l'ain
que vous ne voulez bien évidemment dont
vous êtes élu sur l'apprentissage
j'ai reconnu ici dans cet hémicycle y
avait eu des erreurs au début de ce
quinquennat
qu'en est il aujourd'hui l'apprentissage
est reparti dans la fonction publique
nous avions 700 apprentis nous en avons
dix mille et en effet l'apprentissage
n'est pas une voie pour lutter contre le
chômage
l'apprentissage est une voie
d'excellence c'est une voie d'excellence
et sept jeunes sur dix aujourd'hui
trouver un emploi et nous le savons bien
dans l'artisanat
ce sont les employeurs de demain quelle
est notre constat aujourd'hui leds tpe
jeunes apprentis vous en avez parlé non
ça a permis justement de relancer
l'apprentissage dans les petites
entreprises
c'est une vraie voie d'excellence et
nous avons continué à innover en ouvrant
les titres professionnels du ministère à
l'apprentissage
enfin vous m'interrogez sur la formation
permettez moi de parler des emplois
d'avenir qui ont permis la moitié des
jeunes en emplois d'avenir a eu accès à
la formation l'information ce n'est pas
des stages comme vous avez souvent
l'habitude ou comme le candidat vous
soutenez al'habitude de rappeler la
formation les les axes de formation
prioritaire permettent à 60% des
personnes les plus en difficulté de
trouver un emploi derrière cela permet
d'améliorer la qualification tout autant
que la garantie jeunes nous sommes fiers
d'avoir peur
imada